as radical groups take over cities with
looters ransacking businesses and
torching cars and buildings president
Trump has vowed to take action and
designate an tyfa as a terrorist
organization Dana I want to go to you
first New York's top Terror official I
think his name is John Miller said
there's evidence that these anarchist
groups are far left groups planned to
incite violence using organized Scouts
medic said medics they had rocks bottles
and accelerants for these breakaway
groups that would get inside the protest
and use encrypted communication and then
break out and cause their problems but
basically under the veil of the
protesters and it's I I you know I would
put this to you that my feeling is that
there
the protesters should be the angriest
aside from the people being beaten
senseless the protest should be would be
should be extremely angry about how
they're being used yeah for this violent
display I so yeah I hope that everybody
has a chance to listen to John Miller
this is a great Patriot somebody who has
worked at the FBI he's been a journalist
and now he's been at the NYPD when he
speaks I think people should listen and
in fact I hope to have him on the daily
briefing this week because one of the
things Greg just an anecdote that I
heard about this happened in Nashville
where a young african-american male
peaceful protester turned to the white
people who are throwing bricks saying
stop it please this is not what this is
about and they are going to blame us
and that was distressing to me and if I
could see the rest of my time I do think
that this is maybe you're gonna ask
judge Jeanine anyway but RICO violations
seems to me something that the Justice
Department might look at when it comes
to dealing with the leadership if you
can find them of auntie foe cuz that's
where the money is ah judge take that
question and answer it well Dana Dana is
absolutely right
Rikka was something that can be used you
know when the president said that he was
designating an Tifa as a terrorist
organization the question that everyone
had was what significance does that have
the United States does not have a
domestic terrorism law we have a foreign
terrorism law
and so prosecutors are going to be left
to try to handle cases under Rico and
citing to riot but what we now know is
that Bill Bar and the Justice Department
through the joint terrorist task forces
throughout the country that local DA's
are engaged in as I was when I was the
DA in Westchester will be engaged in
sharing of intelligence and information
so we can identify who the organizers
are and share the information that Dana
was talking about in the earlier segment
there are crimes to which they can be
prosecuted but it usually is the
Secretary of State who designates
someone as a foreign terrorist
organization and then you get the
Secretary of Treasury who's able to
withhold the monies and seize the assets
there will be parallel situations like
that with these domestic terrorists and
you know right now we don't need
additional laws but we can use the RICO
statutes where we go up to the
organizers take them apart and use
whatever resources we have to take the
money and put them in jail one you you
have to agree that an tyfa has marred
what could have been a really great
thing they have taken something that
could potentially be healing between
because people were all in agreement
about this crime and they've turned it
into something else
yeah that's what I said to you in the
first Simon I think that the violent
protest is to be condemned and I don't
know that you know who's behind it I
mean I think that there's this easy easy
labeling this you know anti-fascist
group and they were opposed to the
fashion they're the ones that in
Charlottesville you remember were
fighting against the fascists who were
coming in with their guns and the like
so the question in my mind is the
president designates them as some kind
of terrorist group I don't understand I
mean what are you saying that people who
are socialist people who are communist
anarchists that's now illegal in America
I don't know what I know about Auntie
Fizz very limited but I have been able
to discern that there is no leadership
here there's no hierarchy and oftentimes
I think it's a bunch of young people
who really just don't like the system
are angry about something or the other
and they come out at these opportunities
and in that sense they are opportunist
and again I think they are exploiting
what I think is like 99% of people even
people with their children going out to
protest what happened with George Floyd
you know Jesse Juan made a very
important point
he's very limited on the knowledge of an
tyfa and i would agree because they have
caused a lot of violence we they've
stopped speeches they've hurt a lot of
people they are not misguided freedom
fighters or teenagers they are actually
organized I will tell you what they did
they blocked highways and bridges to
thin the police out that allowed for the
crime wave in high-end areas which was
planned they used accelerants they
placed the bottles in the end stones
which could be used under the canard of
a protest understanding the cowardice of
liberal governance because this is
happening in liberal cities sorry Jesse
I just did a monologue
I mean Juan's knowledge of Antigua
should not be limited we've been
covering it for almost two and a half
years I don't know if he's saying maybe
they're fine people on both sides I
can't understand what he's saying what I
do know is that anything if it's the
very definition of domestic terrorism
and we need to knock these guys out fast
because they've now hijacked this legit
protest and totally disgraced the memory
of George Floyd I got a call last night
from a family friend a female who has
young children in Minneapolis and she
says now she was a member of the
protests at the beginning very liberal
woman and now she has said that this is
pure terrorism they're lighting fires
all over her city they've attacked the
music School where she sends her
daughter to this is not a legit protests
anymore if you're a member of a protest
that's been co-opted into a criminal
uprising I'd stop protesting because I
wouldn't want to associate myself with
violence like that people are scared
people are angry and I think the rest of
the country has had it with this
so-called protest because that
not what it is anymore